I just discovered face dance which is  like an app game  it's like DDR for your face and I think  it's the funniest [ __ ] I've ever seen so  I'm about to go around the office and  make all of my co-workers look  ridiculous  [Music]  I just feel like he's passing out my am  i copying this one dropping the emoji  start floating by  [Music]  crazy time  [Music]  [Applause]  getting jack  [Music]  oh god is it ever over  I'm over stimulated I can't do it that  is what it feels like to like watch  seven toddlers at once and do just too  much going on I think it's a good  bathroom game if I'm on the toilet in  public it's a little more awkward it was  an interesting experience but it's  strangely fun I would never play this in  public that I got into play it's the  fact that I got the lowest points and I  believe it it's fine it's fine  eighteen seventy that's terrible Jake  you got the high score out of the Alan  morning is a habit  [Music]  [Applause]